so while we were at whip we were
reminded of this strange contraption
which is the high level isolation unit
in london the royal free hospital in
london in england which is used as an
isolation facility or a quarantine
facility mostly for hemorrhagic diseases
so this is me inside a trexler unit but
the way it works is that the person who
is either suspected of having ebola or
has it
hops inside this tent and the doctors
and nurses caring for them
just kind of sort of insert themselves
into these suits built into the tent
wall this is me inside it uh immediately
after the dr jacobs told me that they
had cleaned it using an experimental
decontamination procedure after the last
inhabitant left that was a scottish
nurse with ebola so um
there i am there he is and he as he
explains all he has to do and i i quote
him is imaginate himself into the wall
uh to provide care and so what what's
interesting about this
is
the uk is completely unique in doing
isolation this way and and actually mike
jacobs told us
they get rid ridiculed for this people
laugh at them everywhere else in the
world
provides care for people with infectious
diseases using ppe
and this is a this is jeff you might not
recognize him here on the left in full
pbe with our guide to quarantine who we
met in venice who turned out to be the
chief scientific officer in charge of
italy's kovid response later he had jeff
dress up in ppe to sort of show us
what this is like it's extremely hot
it's extremely hard to put on and take
off without the risk of infection that's
something that people train repeatedly
and still get wrong and you also look
like an alien whereas in the trexler
unit when you're invaginated into the
wall
you are not as hot you don't look like
an alien and anyone can do it so
non-trained experts can do it and also
family members can do it so this became
interesting to us and apparently
interesting to others too
we were talking to
doctors who were caring for ebola
patients in the drc in 2018 and they
were telling us we have a really hard
time persuading people to go into
quarantine and isolation because the
culture is
don't be separate from your family
particularly when you're sick that's
just absolutely not the right thing to
do and so people would just resist
quarantine and isolation well congolese
doctors saw the trexler unit and adapted
it for use in the congo these are these
low budget versions of the cube that
have been extremely effective
and to us
that was
kind of a reminder that quarantine can
be redesigned and that something that is
keeping you separate from your community
for your protection and for their
protection cannot still be designed in
such a way that it keeps you connected
to your community
interestingly and we were fascinated to
see this at the start of the covet
pandemic this was adopted in in the us
too so there was some prototype units
being rolled out in boston in june um
that's a hug suit built into the wall of
one of these cubes and what's
fascinating about this is you probably
remember there was this shortage of ppe
well
one of these units replaces 200 full
sets of ppe
again allows family members to visit and
everyone doesn't have to look like an
alien
and it can pop up anywhere so when the
hospitals were getting overwhelmed this
was a viable sort of way to provide care
outside of a ward so really interesting
for us to be imaginative and redesign
quarantine as an experience